welcome everyone to this new episode of
from learning probably wonder where i am
right now this for sure is a bit of an
unusual location i'm currently in
switzerland so yesterday i took the
train from munich to zangalan and the
business heavy people probably know that
sangalan is the hometown of the
university zanggan the hoshu le
which is arguably the best university in
the german speaking area so i'm lecturer
for the mba program at san garland for
communication and slight writing topics
it's not the first time that we are back
in class in the lecture rooms away from
online teaching due to the situation so
i'm very excited for this new
opportunity this new experience here so
you will now follow me for the day i
will share a couple of insights on what
it's like to do an mba in general do an
mba at zangalan so trust this video will
be insightful to everyone who wants to
know what it's like to do an mba and
potentially also whether an mba is the
right thing for you to do so let's do it
let's start
at university of zangalan i teach at the
full time and the part-time mba program
especially focus on topics such as
professional communication slight
writing techniques and also many of
these other topics that you are very
familiar with if you regularly follow
the channel this is really a passion of
mine so i'm very happy to be able to
contribute to the business education of
the future leaders in this way it's
really amazing just thinking back how a
couple of years ago i was sitting on the
other side of this room here really at
the desk not at sangai but at
mba program and now being able being
honored to teach here this is a great
experience today we've talked a lot
about top-down communication forming
storylines for your presentations so all
these skills that surely come in handy
in all different types of business
presentation context because in the end
of the day this is what the mba is all
about it's not only about academia but
really also learning these more softer
professional skills that of course are
so important to present well to
communicate well do this in front of
very senior audiences do this in front
of board members this is exactly what
you will learn in the mba where also i
personally took so much away at my ncr
experience so here with me i have
federica from the mba class of zhang
garden of 2022 thank you for joining me
federica thank you for inviting me can
you share a little bit about your
background what did you do prior to the
mba yes of course i'm italian
i've studied
mathematics in italy and then had a bit
of experience in project management
mainly in the fashion industry
so what is the course here in zhang that
so far you enjoyed most what was the
most significant learning for you i have
to say that i really enjoyed capital
markets
course this is something i really never
did before
but a teaching method was so
diverse and also we had the impression
to really learn
something that is happening in the world
and very important for every mba student
that very much resonates because this is
also my experience when i did my mba or
maybe for the uninitiated out there can
you share a couple of thoughts on like
what's distinctive about the mba
teaching method how does it work here in
zangai what makes it special of course
so i've studied in italy university and
the methodology was completely different
like a professor telling you things
things same things you have to study a
lot and then finally have an exam here
the story is completely different you
always have group works to do different
methods like
of course frontal lessons but also
discussions
uh workshops and a lot of exams also
exactly i mean that's really i think the
point of an mba it's not so much about
academia but it's really about hands-on
management and business knowledge and
this of course is what makes it valuable
do you happen to look back at the last
weeks already one key memorable moment
that you want to share
so
first of all i have to say that the
first day of mba was memorable because
it was the first time being together
with almost 50 people in the same big
room and you know after this covet
period this was so strange to be all
together uh
really shaking hands and meeting people
that were all really happy to start this
journey together this was the super
the the most exciting moment i have to
say so that's amazing thank you
appreciate it
so it's a pleasure to also meet you
alisa you're also part of the current
mba cohort so i'm standing here with
payet who's also part of the current mba
class thank you mcloy for taking your
time as well part of the current mba
cohort at zangalan thank you for joining
me mate much appreciated thank you ali
for joining me here as well at the
university of zangalan so before the mba
i was a finance professional i've got
around five years of experience with the
fmcg industry but i've lived in the last
six years in finland and i was working
in operational procurement for and
manufacturing company uh so i worked in
financial industries i was a regional
manager in insurance company
last year before joining the mba i spent
a year in digital transformation of the
same 120 year old insurance company
and i also co-founded to two companies
i was working in ministry of treasury
and finance for for the last nine years
the last three years i worked as a
project manager and government consulter
i
am a phd in music theory
i was a concert pianist before that i've
been working as a sustainability
consultant so far what i really like
here is that we get to meet all these
different companies because that's
something that you don't really get to
do at school or in your normal work so
of course like
being exposed to so many companies is
something that i really appreciate for
example on the turkey day i went to a
company called on running and after that
i went to the crypto finance so i think
i was particularly impressed that our
accounting professor tommy din started
her first entire lecture talking about
environmental accounting measures which
i thought was very important especially
for the present moment
in the first week we had to uh launch
rocket uh we didn't know how to do it
but we we we sat down we were the
diverse team and uh
i would wish to say that our that we we
launched till till the moon but our
rocket exploded but it was a great
learning experience so let's go to the
moon thank you absolutely thanks the
university of zangaran is the leading
university in the german speaking area
so i feel very honored that i've been
asked to conduct here the lecture for
the mba program here with me i have
zander from the university team of zhang
if you're interested in doing an mba and
want to learn more
about general business finance strategy
and a lot in communication or career
development
click on the link below to learn more
about our mba at the university of san
gala
i did an mba myself i did my mba at
insead in 2015 and 2016. i was working
on both campuses in france and in
singapore and really had the full
experience there i just wanted to share
with you the top three reasons or top
three things that i got out of the mba
for myself and i hope of course this
helps potentially also you to decide
whether this is something that makes
sense for you too and the first is for
sure amazing connections so especially
the inside mbb but i trust you also
zangalin it's no different you meet so
many people in the mba program from so
many different regions and geographies i
know for myself that if i all want to
travel in almost every country in the
world it's more or less guaranteed that
i will know a person there that at least
will be able to have someone introduce
me there to a person to a local who can
maybe guide me around potentially even
give me a place to sleep and of course
this is a network that also on the
professional side is extremely valuable
i recently was looking for contacts at a
specific company i was looking that
company up on linkedin and i saw that
several of my old mba friends were
working at that company that of course
is huge and really a great opportunity
to tap into the second is the mba being
a wildcard that you can pull out so
frankly this is not really the way how i
used it but i saw that many other people
used it is that they do the mba because
they want to make a career transition
and this i think is an opportunity that
many people have then maybe you work in
a specific industry or maybe you work on
a specific function and you want to do a
switch and to some extent i think the
mba is something that is used to really
reset your career that is often really
also accepted by employers that after
you did an mba
do something completely different and
this is actually also an opportunity
where i see that people want to get into
consulting maybe in a firm like mckinsey
bcg bain so these mbb consulting firms
if they have a background maybe in big
four for instance then they can indeed
use an mba to then also do this switch
because frankly it's sometimes very
difficult to then transition from ig
consulting or from mc4 to mab but if you
do the mba this is often a great
opportunity to do exactly that and last
but not least of course it's also the
learnings and what learning is exactly
what we get out of it will also depend
on the type of program that you do so
the one thing of course are the lectures
the input that you get here you of
course you will benefit most if you have
don't have a business background yet so
if you're for instance an engineer i've
never attended a business lecture this
will then of course be really great and
eye opening for you for me personally i
already did have some business education
so i still learned something new but
probably the biggest takeaway from their
perspective was really the cultural
awareness so for me having spent half of
the program in singapore traveling to
lots of asian countries in southeast
asia spending several weeks in china for
instance the experiences that i did
there the cultural sensitivity that this
gave to me was really eye-opening for me
i took so much away from that and which
was a fundamental part of for my
personal learning experience that i had
during the mba so i hope you found this
insightful if you have any more
questions on what it's like to do an mba
please leave me a comment below in the
comments section once again if you want
to read more about the university of san
ganin and the mba link to the
information pages below in the video
description they're happy to reach out
to you provide you with all the
information that is needed again if you
took any value out of this video at all
please hit the like button for the
youtube algorithm and also very big
thanks to all the members of from
learning thanks for our support my name
is heinrich i'm the host here at from
learning i release videos every single
saturday so see you again next week
until then all the best and bye